[Musique]
merci Dominique Verrien d'être avec nous
pendant cette première demi-heure vous
êtes élu lion membre du groupe Union
centriste présidente de la délégation au
droit des femmes et à l'égalité des
chances entre les hommes et les femmes
ici au Sénat et on va parler dans
quelques instants de l'audition d'Éric
dupupont moréti sur le budget de la
justice puisque vous en êtes également
la rapporteur d'abord on l'a vu dans
l'actualité c'est l'affaire de crépool
et ces suites qui agite la classe
politique des manifestations violente de
groupes d'ultra drroite ont eu lieu
après ce drame Gérald haranin hier il a
pointé le risque d'un scénario de guerre
civile est-ce que vous diriez cela aussi
alors non je parlerai pas de guerre
civile je pense que les groupes d'ultard
droite sont
à surveillé on le sait partout en Europe
sauf en France les attentats sont faits
par des groupes d'ultra droite en France
il se trouve que nous sont plutôt des
attentats islamistes mais donc évitons
que les uns alimentent les autres et
qu'on en arrive là donc je pense qu'il
faut les surveiller les contraindre
comme le fait Gérald daranin mais pas
attiser ça n'est pas nécessaire c'est
pas la peine d'atiser les braises je
pense qu'il faut plus réfléchir à
comment on évite demain d'être les uns
contre les autres il a eu raison de
demander la dissolution de certains
comppuscules d'ultradroite ah je crois
que oui il a eu raison de demander la
dissolution alors comment on évite
d'être les uns contre les autres c'est
ce que vous dites est-ce qu'on est sur
les deux Frances face à face c'est ce
que disait Gérard colon alors j'ai j'
esppère qu'on en est pas encore arrivé
là je je crains que le conflit
israelllo-palestinien déteigne un petit
peu et provoque encore un petit peu plus
la la cassure entre entre les deux
mondes mais justement là c'est à nous de
travailler je sais que dans toutes les
communes où on a des des
cités où l'ambiance est un petit peu
tendue les les maires font vraiment
énormément d'efforts pour pour apaiser
je pense qu'on a eu mais moi je suis
rentrée en politique en suivant
Jean-Louis borlot et et l'en rue je
crois qu'on a eu une politique de
d'habitat qui fait qu'aujourd'hui on a
plus ou moins mis les uns contre les
autres parce que ils n'habitent pas
forcément ensemble et donc quand on se
connais pas c'est plus compliqué je
crois que il faut manque de mixité c'est
une des explication il faut qu'on
poursuive vers plus de mixité oui euh
pourquoi on en arrive parce que c'est le
cas aujourd'hui à des groupes uscules
qui cherchent à faire justice à la place
de la justice puisquon parler dans
quelques instants des questions de
justice al je je crois que même si alors
effectivement on sa que la justice est
lente mais je crois que c'est pas le
sujet je crois que même si la justice
était rapide de toute façon ils ont
envie de se battre enfin c'est c'est pas
du tout un phénomène de justice qui
vraiment les anime je pense que ils ont
envie de de casser celui du camp d'en
face beaucoup plus sûrement on va parler
de l'audition d'éc d pontorti dans
quelques instants mais on l'a vu dans le
journal hier à l'Assemblée nationale et
Éric Dupont Moretti il s'en est pris au
rassemblement national euh en disant je
cite au députés RN vous préférez opposer
la France rurale et tranquille
catholique et blanche à la France des
cités des Mohamed des Mouloud des
rachides vos propos sont incendiaires et
ils amènent dans la rue des militants
d'ultradroite il a eu raison de parler
comme ça je crois qu'on a jamais raison
d'attiser les braises quoi qu'il en soit
et je crois que si on a une parole
politique elle doit plutôt être mesurée
euh voilà alors après ce qu'il a dit est
pas forcément faux mais euh il aurait
pas dû le dire dans les pas forcément
nécessaire et Marine Le qui a annoncé
dans la foulée son intention de porter
plainte alors je crois que porter
plainte pourquoi pour diffamation
dit-elle diffamation est-ce que c'est de
la diffamation que de voir que le
RN prospère sur le fait de diviser la
France rurale de la France urbaine euh
et les blancs catholiques des musulmans
on va continuer à parler d'Éric du pomti
puisque vous l'avez auditionné hier
aprèsmidi au Sénat sur le budget de la
justice donc vous êtes la rapporteur on
va voir l' en fort de cette audition
avec notre journaliste Parlement comment
[Musique]
Jourdin bonjouron bonjour ran bonjour
madame la sénatrice et le Sénat entamé
jeudi dans l'hémicycle les discussion
sur le budget 2024 et hier Éric Dupont
morti était auditionné sur le budget
justice oui sur ça et sur rien d'autre
on gu gêter une éventuelle sortie d'Éric
DUP Moretti sur son procès devant la CJR
pour prise illégale d'intérêt la Cour de
Justice de la République qui doit rendre
publique sa décision aujourd'hui ça
devrait être cet après-midi mais rien
non rien les sénateurs ont été très pro
l'audition s'est concentrée sur le
budget pour l'année prochaine à cette
occasion éric dupomoretti a mis en avant
la hausse des crédits de la justice
écoutez l'ambition de ce nouveau budget
est d'abord d'améliorer la qualité de la
justice qui doit être rendu au
justiciable venant s'ajouter à des
années d'augmentation ayant permis au
budget du ministère de passer de
6,9 milliards d'euros en 2017 à
9,6 milliards d'euros en 2023 la hausse
se poursuivra en
2024 sans se payer de mots je pense que
l'on peut dire que c'est historique dans
le détail les crédits de la justice vont
effectivement augmenter largement ils
vont atteindre les 10,1 milliards
d'euros en 2024 c'est 503 millions de
plus que cette année que 2023 parmi les
grandes mesures à à retenir on retrouve
notamment la création de 10000 emplois
d'ici à 2027 dont 1500 magistrats et
1500 grffiers il a été question
d'informatique aussi oui c'est un sujet
que vous suivez particulièrement madame
Verrien il y a 3 ans la commission des
finances du Sénat avait demandé une
enquête à la Cour des comptes sur les
retards de notre justice en matière de
numérique les résultats ils étaient
éloquents le matériel les applications
été jugé vêtu lente et pas vraiment
fiable aujourd'hui encore Éric DUP
Moretti le reconnaît c'est toujours pas
ça
écoutez le plantage pardon je m'exprime
de façon familière de la bécane un
vendredi soir c'est
insupportable ça génère de de de la
frustration de la difficulté alors on
remontait d'abord l'info à la DSJ quand
c'était pas au secrétariat général voire
au de le temps que les deux se
connectent bon voilà puis on n' pas des
techniciens informatiques pour attraper
le retard en matière de de numérique le
budget de l'année prochaine prévoit
notamment le recrutement de techniciens
100 techniciens ont été ou vont être
recrutés en 2023 et 100 nouveaux
techniciens seront recrutés en 2024
madame Verrien dans quelle mesure notre
justice est en retard en matière de
numérique et dans quelle mesure ces
annonces de Dupont Moretti et bien vont
suffir alors ces annonces ne suffiront
probablement pas mais il y a deux choses
au niveau de la justice il y a
effectivement les plantages réguliers le
fait d'avoir besoin d'assistance et ces
techniciens seront vraiment les
bienvenus et puis il y a le fait qu'on
narrive pas à se sortir des gros
dossiers c'estàd que les petites
application sortent et ça ça se passe
relativement bien mais alors les gros
dossiers comme Portalis ou
ciopé alors Portalis c'est le dossier
c'est le le le logiciel qui doit
normalement gérer toute la partie civile
qu'on a attend depuis que je suis
sénatrice je crois et qui va arriver
j'espère avant que je j'arrête d'être
sénatrice mais on en est pas totalement
sûr euh une première partie va être
déployée normalement cette année ça
devait être en septembre on c'est pas
encore arrivé partout apparemment sur
ne9 site c'est déjà là pour portalist au
niveau des prudomes ça doit être déployé
un peu plus après attendons de voir mais
aujourd'hui on a un peu de souci puisque
Portalis au niveau des cours d'appel
alors non ça c'est Copé alors ça c'est
Portalis C c'est ce qui gère le pénal et
c'est ce qui plante en permanence c'est
sur Cassiopé ils arrivent pas à mettre à
jour régulièrement en fonction
malheureusement des avancé lgistique qui
al je dis malheureusement parce qu'on
nous reproche de faire trop de lois et
donc c'est difficile à intégrer de façon
régulière mais on a dans le type de
plantage un greffier qui va mettre une
peine complémentaire va la taper sur son
ordinateur et donc sur la fiche quand
elle va s'imprimer ce sera pas imprimé
alors on parle il y a un objectif de
zéro pi pour 2027 on en est où on est en
bonne voie bah non la procédure c'est
pareil bah non mais et je pense que
c'est même pas un objectif à suivre zéro
papier c'est pas à suivre bah pas tout
de suite pas tout de suite déjà ayons
des logiciels qui fonctionnent bien et
une fois que ça fonctionnera bien on
aura plus besoin du papier mais là on se
rend bien compte que évidemment qu'ils
prennent du papier à côté parce que
quand ça plante bah il faut bien avoir
quelque chose sur quoi se s'appuyer
c'est la 4e hausse consécutive pour le
budget de de la la justice alors je
parlais de 1500 greffi en fait c'est
1800 greffié pour pour l'année prochaine
vous saluez cette hausse elle était
nécessaire ou oui bien sûr et d'ailleurs
les 1800 nous les avons obtenu de haute
lutte avec agès canailler pendant le la
loi de programmation sur la justice
c'est absolument nécessaire je ne suis
pas sûr d'ailleurs que ce soit suffisant
vous savez queon a les pôles spécialisés
qui arrivve donc ça je j'ai confiance je
sais qu'ils vont se mettre en place mais
ça va prendre forcément un peu de force
vive les dossiers seront forcément
traité de façon un peu plus lente donc
on a réellement besoin d'avoir plus de
magistrats donc je pense que dans c'est
une première vague mais je suis pas sûr
que ce soit suffisant mais est-ce que
quand même ce budget qui dépasse les 10
milliards ça montre l'AMB Miss du
gouvernement pour la non mais c'est très
bien c'était voilà c'était c'est
conséquent mais c'était nécessaire c'est
clair est-ce que vous êtes d'accord avec
les priorités les objectifs de ce budget
parce que derrière ces 10 milliards il y
a des objectifs alors oui ben sur les
objectifs bien sûr après c'est sur la
façon dont on arrive à les tenir
maintenant sur le recrutement où
certains s'inquiètent je sais que
l'école nationale la magistrature comme
l'école nationale des greffes sont en
ordre de bataille pour pouvoir
accueillir plus euh de de d'étudiants et
donc du coup ça nous permettra d'avoir
plus rapidement des magistrats plus de
magistrats et plus de greffiers donc ça
c'est bien non je pense que réellement
on est on est sur la bonne voie sur les
places de prison euh on évoque la
construction la création de 15000
nouvelles places de prison on en est où
je sais que le le Sénat était très
offensif là-dessus é dupomtier a l'air
de dire dire bon 10000 ok 15000 ça sera
peut-être plus compliqué bah oui et puis
18 encore moins mais on en est où bah ça
avance mais on sait bien aussi alors là
je leur jetterai pas la pierre même si
on sait que ces places sont nécessaires
ne serait-ce que pour avoir des
conditions dignes
d'incarcération mais ensuite on sait
qu'une prison c'est long à construire on
sait qu'il faut avoir des autorisations
d'urbanisme et que les prisons sont pas
toujours bien accueillliis sur les
territoires sur lesquels elles
souhaitent s'implanter donc il y a un
travail qui est de longue haline c'est
clair sur votre territoire il y aura des
nouvelles non nous en avons deux déjà et
a priori nous n avons pas une troisième
pour 350000 habitants c'est bien de
prison dont une qui est spécialisée en
auteur d'infraction sexuelle on on va en
parler est-ce que un tel budget garantit
pour autant une réponse pénale
efficace alors pas
forcément effectivement l'argent suffit
pas après il faut avoir
l'organisation et et les personnes qui
sont là alors objectivement quand on va
dans les juridictions on voit bien qu'
là aussi ils ont envie de de toute façon
de d'avancer de bien faire
euh ils s'organise pour cela mais ils
ont besoin de forces vives donc quand
les forces vives arriveront je pense que
ce sera effectivement plus simple mais
là aussi je pense vraiment que même 1500
et 1800 sera pas forcément totalement
nécess ça garanti pas une accélération
des procédures une réponse Judici par
c'est en parallèle on a aussi une
demande de justice et de justice plus
rapide donc ça va bon voilà il faut
s'organiser cela dit ce qui est en train
de se passer est plutôt positif et on
devrait aller vers effectivement du
mieux Steve non non si peut-être en
matière de numérique parce que
j'aimerais revenir juste là-dessus
qu'est-ce que vous demandez concrètement
à Eric Dupont Moretti aujourd'hui c'est
votre sujet en rappelle un pilote en
faitour bah je me demande je me demande
donc j'aimerais effectivement constater
que il y a un pilote qui fait avancer
surtous les deux gros dossiers dont j'ai
parlé un Portalis et Cup parce que pour
le reste ça semble bien fonctionner mais
et qui prennent en charge le le les
vraies
demandes pilote voulait dire de de
gouvernement ou quelqu'un qui soit nommé
au ministère non mais à la Chancellerie
qui est quelqu'un qui s'y connaissent
qui comprennent le projet le problème et
puis qu'il prennent à bras le corps pour
que enfin ça sorte je alors l'année
dernière ils nous ont dit qu'il y avait
pas de problème ils s'organisait bon je
constate que Portal est quand même
toujours pas installé mais et que
Cassiopé il m'a pas répondu à ma
question d'ailleurs je lui posé la
question Portalis et Cup j'ai une
réponse sur Portalis parce que ça semble
enfin commencer à aboutir j'ai aucune
réponse sur Cassiopé et quand il y a pas
de réponse à mon avis c'est pas parce
que
tu c'est aujourd'hui que sera rendu le
la décision de la Cour de Justice de la
République sur l'affaire Éric Dupont
moréti qui est soupçonné de conflit
d'intérêts est-ce qu'il est un ministre
affaibli
en tout cas hier il semblait pas l'être
donc on est affaibli quand on a plus la
confiance de son chef en l'occurrence du
président de la République qui semble
encore lui faire confiance maintenant
attendons 15h on saura en fonction de du
résultat s'il est ou non affaibli s'il
est condamné il doit démissionner pour
vous ça me paraît personnellement oui je
pense que ça va être compliqué pour lui
s il est condamné de de pouvoir
continuer merci St tout à l'heure on
parlera de crépolisation du Parlement ce
sera à suivre dans le club on va aller
du côté de Ch qu' n'en arrive pas au
main quand même on va aller on va voir
l'actualité chez vous on va dans Lyonne
à oser on retrouve Antoine Compigne
bonjour Antoine merci d'être avec nous
journaliste à Lyonne républicaine et à
lire ce matin dans Lyon républicaine
Antoine un dossier complet sur le procès
de Monique Olivier l'ex épouse du tueur
en série Michel fourni procès qui s'est
ouvert hier
oui bonjour Orian bonjour madame la
sénatrice donc oui comme vous dis hier
c'est ouvert à enterre le procès de
Monique Olivier donc c'est un procès qui
a un important retentissement dans notre
département puisque deux victimes de
Michel fronir se trouvaient dans Lyonne
marieangel domes et Johanna parich il y
a beaucoup d'attentes autour de de de
cette audience car des familles
attendent des réponses depuis près de 35
ans du coup je voulais donc vous
demander madame Verrien si pour vous la
justice était aujourd'hui mieux armée
pour traiter de de telles affaires en
2023 notamment avec la la création du
pôle colquaz à ananter bah c'était ce
que j'allais répondre la création du
Paul colquez normalement devrait aider
effectivement à à régler euh C ces ces
problèmes enfin ces sujets là c'est ces
dossiersl donc effectivement je pense
que c'est plutôt une bonne chose et on a
bah l'avocat maître Seban qui est très
attentif on avait passé justement par
rapport à ça quelques amendements pour
que le paôul colquais puisse vraiment
bien fonctionner donc oui oui et puis
c'est vrai que le département de Lyonne
a payé tr sur ce genre de entre
Fourniret et et Émile Louis et les
autres c'est vrai qu'on est un
département très
attentif aux violences faites aux
enfants ou aux
femmes Antoine on passe à un autre sujet
oui bah justement ça va être un petit
peu en lien avec avec cette thématique
là le le 13 novembre dernier vous avez
accueilli dans Lyonne Beranger Couillard
la mise déléguée en charge de l'égalité
entre les femmes et les hommes et et la
lutte contre les les discriminations
vous avez pu lui montrer quelques
réalisations concrètes du plan rougeevf
le rapport de 59 propositions que vous
aviez coécrit avec la la députée
Renaissance Émilie Chandler pour lutter
plus efficacement contre les les
violences
intrafamiliales aujourd'hui entre la
création du pack nouveau départ la
possibilité d'obtenir peut-être des des
ordonnances de protection en moins de 24
heures est-ce que vous avez le sentiment
qu'on accélère enfin sur le sujet alors
on accélère je voudrais quand même dire
que l'ordonnance de protection sous 24
heures ce sera quand Émilie chandel aura
déposé sa proposition de loi à
l'Assemblée et qu'elle sera votée dans
nos deux assemblées donc c'est pas
encore tout de suite mais j'espère que
ça se fera rapidement lespaule l'épaule
vif qui sont déjà mis en place dans
certains endroits et qui se mettent en
place y compris dans Lyonne mais partout
sur le territoire d'ailleurs à sens ils
vont appel ça l'épaule rouge
vif les choses avancent les gendarmes et
les policiers qui se forment et nous
avons un colonel de gendarmerie le
colonel Nani dans Lyonne qui est très
volontaire sur ce sujet qui ont fait
vraiment sa priorité alors c'est vrai
que c'est un fléo donc c'est bien de
lutter contre mais c'est bien d'avoir un
gendarme à ce point engagé donc oui
réellement on voit les choses avancer et
puis les élus ruraux référents de
l'égalité qui là encore partent de
Lyonne grâce à Dominique chapui qui est
notre président de l'association des
mères ruraux et qui se décline sur toute
la France de telle sorte que en ruralité
où on sait que 47 % des féminicides se
déroulent alors que nous ne sommes que
30 % de la population il faut avoir des
relais pour pouvoir et des relais bien
formés pour pouvoir reconnaître une
femme victime et essayer de
l'accompagner vers l'association qui
pourra la prendre en charge
éventuellement vers la plainte vers la
rupture et cetera et donc je suis très
heureuse je crois qu'on a plus de 200
référents égalité dans Lyon déjà et ça
se déploie bien au niveau national donc
voilà c'est Lyonne est un petit
territoire de d'expérimentation enfin
moi je le prend un peu comme ça et et on
a une un très bon alignement de Planète
ce que je disais entre entre le le
colonel de gendarmerie une déléguée au
droits des femmes Juliette rom
extraordinaire les présidents et
procureurs que soit à sens ou à oser
très engagés et donc c'est vrai que ça
permet d'avancer et de montrer que ça
fonctionne merci Antoine merci beaucoup
d'avoir été avec nous Antoine compig on
regarde la Une de liyonne républicaine
c'est Monique Olivier vous nous en
parliez Monique Olivier et ses regrets
c'est à la Une de votre journal merci
beaucoup avec évidemment deux pages à
lire sur ce procès qui s'est ouvert hier
merci Antoine compine merci d'avoir été
avec nous on va qu'on va parler des
violences faites au femmes Dominique
Verrien puisqu'on le rappelle vous êtes
la la présidente de la délégation au
droits des femmes ici au Sénat 244000
victimes ont porté plainte victime de
violence conjugale ont porté plainte en
2022 il y a eu 118 féminicide samedi
Emmanuel Macron a posté une vidéo sur
les réseaux sociaux dans laquelle il dit
je le cite la persistance de la violente
faite aux femmes n'est pas une fatalité
nous devons y mettre fin et nous allons
le faire comment vous avez reçu ce
message et bien je me suis dit que si
d'ici la fin de son mandat il arrivé à
changer la nature humaine je lui tirais
vraiment mon chapeau je pense que c'est
un peu ambitieux de se dire qu'on va
l'éradiquer euh veillons déjà à faire
que comment c'est présomptueux m c'est
bah oui c'est c'est très
présomptueux mais si ça lui permet de
mettre tous les moyens pour avancer dans
ce sens c'est toujours bon à prendre
mais évidemment je crois pas que ici la
fin du quinena il arrive à faire ça euh
et d'ailleurs si on veut vraiment lutter
efficacement parce que c'est vraiment un
problème de changement de mentalité
qu'il faut faire reprenons et et
appliquons la loi dans les écoles avec
les cours
d'éducation à la vie affective et
sexuelle al évidemment on va pas dire la
même chose en maternel que au collège
mais c'est très important il faut
commencer tôt pour vous il faut
commencer tôt déjà parce que ça va
protéger les enfants quand quand on voit
quand on lit le rapport de la civise on
se dit qu'il faut vraiment agir assez
vite pour que un enfant comprenne que
son corps est son corps et que tout le
monde ne peut pas y avoir accès pas même
papa et
donc ça c'est important c'est important
d'apprendre l'égalité d'apprendre le
respect d'apprendre la notion de
consentement et que quand on dit non
c'est non et tout ça c'est vraiment à
l'école qu'il faut faire ce travail or
ce travail ne se fait pas actuellement
donc je l'invite puisqu'il veut vraiment
éradiquer cela de se tourner vers le
ministre de l'éducation nationale et de
veiller que on remette très très
rapidement ses cours en place Emmanuel
Macron qui dans la même vidéo défend he
la la mise en place de mesures et et et
défend ses engagements il parle du
déploiement du fichier de prévention des
violences intrafilial en janvier ça
permet un meilleur suivi des auteurs et
une prise en compte de ce qu'on appelle
les signaux faibles il parle également
de la création de pôles spécialisés dans
tous les tribunaux judiciaire à partir
du 1er janvier vous avez beaucoup
travaillé là-dessus ce sont les bonnes
réponses oui oui oui c'est c'est
important pour euh le problème c'est que
ça c'est pas de la prévention mais après
une fois que ça se passe oui oui il faut
pouvoir punir et l'avantage des pôles
spécialisés c'est que enfin le juge
pénal et le juge civil donc le juge
affffaires familiales et le juge des
enfants vont pouvoir se parler et ne pas
prendre des décisions contradictoires et
donc ils pourront euh étudier la famille
dans sa globalité et prendre des
décisions cohérentes entre ce qui va se
passer dans le divorce les vrais droits
de garde et cetera pour ne pas mettre en
danger cette famille et puis si ces
magistrats sont formés et ces magistrats
doivent se former pour pouvoir rentrer
dans lespaule ils sauront ce que c'est
que le psychotraumatisme ils sauront ce
que c'est que le contrôle coohercitif et
donc ils sauront détectés qu'il y a bien
un auteur et une victime et à ce
moment-là protéger là où les victimes
parce que les enfants sont
systématiquement victimes du moment
qu'ils sont dans un couple qui où où
l'un exerce de la violence sur l'autre
il y a une autre mesure qui va rentrer
en vigueur ce vendredi c'est à
l'initiative de votre ancienne collègue
sénatrice centrist Valérie
c'est l'aide universelle d'urgence pour
les victimes qu'est-ce que ça va changer
alors ça va changer le fait que il y a
pas besoin d'attendre 3 mois pour
pouvoir de nouveau avoir accès à ces
droits donc il y aura l'aide universelle
qui va se déployer mais surtout
parallèlement ça va permettre de traiter
le dossier plus vite et que la femme
retrouve son autonomie puisque on sait
bien que la première des contraintes et
une des raisons pour lesquelle une femme
a du mal à quitter son foyer ou ou ou
son mari parce que l'idée c'est qu'elle
puisse garder son foyer c'est aussi
évidemment le l'objectif vers lequel on
doit tendre c'est la écomtir quand même
ça ça aide à couper ça aide à avoir une
dépendance parce que la dépendance
économique est de la première des
violences je parlais de ruralité la
première dépendance c'est de faire
vendre sa voiture à sa femme en disant
qu'une seule voiture on y arrivera très
bien quand on sait qu'en ruralité on ne
peut pas se déplacer si chacun n'a pas
sa voiture donc ce sont plein de choses
comme ça qui font que c'est pour ça
qu'on je travaille beaucoup sur le
contrôle coercitif c'est toute la NAS
qui est mise autour de la victime pour
qu'elle ne puisse pas s'en sortir et
qu'elle ne parte pas et c'est pour ça
qu'il y a 7 aller-retour si de 7 on peut
passer à deux ou trois ce serait déjà
merveilleux on parlait de ce chiffre de
244000 plaintes qui ont été déposé qui a
un chiffre évidemment alarmant mais
est-ce qu'en même temps ça traduit
peut-être une meilleure prise en compte
de la parole et et et des plaintes qui
sont facilités bien sûr ça traduit
surtout le fait que aujourd'hui les
mains courantes sont interdites c'est
fort forcément une plainte et en plus il
n'y a pas besoin de porter plainte
aujourd'hui pour être pour que le
procureur se saisisse et ça c'est aussi
une grande avancée parce que c'est c'est
évidemment très violent de porter
plainte c'est et puis surtout la femme a
peur d'où l'idée de la l'ordonnance de
protection immédiate qu'on souhaite
mettre en place et qui j'espère arrivera
vite parce que aujourd'hui alors
effectivement on est passé de 40 à 6
jours mais 6 jours pour donner une
protection alors que la femme apporté
tes plaines que le mari le sait
objectivement c'est 6 jours de grand
danger donc là on inverse la chose
c'estàd qu'on donne tout de suite
l'ordonnance et après on a bien 6 jours
pour organiser le contradictoire mais
pour confirmer ou pas le fait queil faut
protéger vous espérez une mise en place
quand mais j'espère début d'année
prochaine enfin l'année prochaine à mon
avis le temps que ça fasse l'aller
retour dans nos deux chambres ce sera je
pense pour Mars mais un autre sujet pour
terminer parce que vous allez mener une
série d'audition une mission flash sur
les familles mono parental pourquoi
cette thématique bah parce que on se
rend compte que la pauvreté en fait
touche principalement des familles
monoparentales parce qu'on se rend
compte que les enfants de famillees
monoparentales ont moins de Chan de
faire des études et donc il faut
forcément prendre en compte ce sujet et
d'ailleurs on parle de familles
monoparentales qui sont majoritairement
des mères avec leurs enfants euh et
c'est il il faut s'interroger de où sont
les pères parce que les pères existent
ce sont des pères qui ont totalement
démissionné qui ne prennent pas en
charge la vie de leurs enfants donc je
pense que il faut effectivement trouver
des solutions alors les problèmes on les
connaît c'est pour ça qu'on fait pas on
fait qu'une mission flash mais il nous
faut vraiment des préconisations et ça
va être ce sur quoi nous allons
travailler là encore pour le début mars
le 8 mars je pense date symbolique un
dernier mot parce qu'il nous reste très
peu de temps Dominique Verrien vous
préparez un autre rapport sur les femmes
sans domicile oui euh parce que on s'est
rendu compte ben dans la rue euh à Paris
on se rend compte qu'il y a de plus en
plus de femmes qui sont à la rue mais de
femmes précaires justement il y en a
beaucoup parce qu'en ruralité on va pas
les trouver euh dans la rue sur un
carton mais euh on sait que elles vont
devoir trouver une solution euh pour
pouvoir habiter et donc à quel prix euh
j'ai rencontré une femme qui est une
accoucheuse de rue c'est-à-dire que
quand une femme est dans la rue c'est
vraiment effroyable c'est euh des
risques de viol de violence et donc
évidemment de tomber enceinte évidemment
de ne pas être suivi et de devoir un
jour accoucher et accoucher dans la rue
enfin c'est ni pour la mère ni pour
l'enfant ça me semble quelque chose de
de souhaitable merci Dominique Verrien